GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY
APRIL SIXTEENTH THIS FOR BY
CALLED ORDERS. OF PLEASE BE
ADVISED AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING ATTENDEES.
PROCEED IS BEING MADE HAS ALSO
BEEN TELEVISED.
BETTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL
COOLEY.
HI HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE.
CURRY UP HERE TORONTO'S FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON HERE MAYES HERE NAZARIAN
PRESENT DOLLARS
WALDRON HERE.
CALPERS.
HERE HERE WE HAVE WHAT. WE HAVE
A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA.
IS OUR MOTION BECAUSE THAT
SOME.
UBER MISS CUNNINGHAM. SECONDED
BY MISTER NAZARIAN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM FIVE CUNNINGHAM I
CARILLO THANKED CARILLO AYE
CERVANTES FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE NOSE AREA.
I KNOW THERE AND I THINK SOLIS
WALDRON. AND WALDRON I.
VERY GOOD THE MOTIONS PASSED AND
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH